Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio 254 vom Chaos Communication Camp 2019 an Tag 4. Mein Name ist, ja weiß ich noch nicht so richtig. Marcus Richter oder Monoxid? Man weiß es nicht so genau. Auf jeden Fall ist es das erste Chaos Radio, nach der wir sind nicht mehr auf Ritz-Dings. Und wir machen das heute so ein bisschen back to the roots, sehr minimalistisch. Wir haben noch keinen neuen Opener. Wir wissen auch nicht so genau, was passiert. Also alles so im Chaos-Style, diskordisch sei es gerade so, wie man heute schon bedeutet. Wir sprechen heute über so ein paar Dinge, die hier auf dem Camp passieren. Das Camp ist eine Veranstaltung alle vier Jahre, wo sich HackerInnen aus aller Welt treffen, Zelte bauen und eine riesige Holzbar oder Holzdorf, wie im Fall von Three-Headed-Monkeys. Und da sitzen wir jetzt auf einer Bühne. Ihr könnt gerne noch vorbeikommen, falls ihr das hört. Und zuhören, zugucken, Schienenfahrzeuge bestaunen und kleine Uhren. Und wie gesagt, wir machen heute drei oder vielleicht vier, man weiß nicht so genau, Projekte, die auf dem Camp stattfinden. Als erstes zu Gast bei mir Julian. Hallo, guten Tag. Hallo. Und als ich gelesen habe, es ist Camp dieses Jahr, diese Veranstaltung, da hatte ich auch sehr viel in meinen Timelines. Ja, die Cardio-Batch, voll geil. Die ist total super. Herzschrittgeräte sind jetzt die Hacker in dem Alter, wo man immer seinen Puls messen muss. Aber nein, ihr erinnert euch vielleicht an den Chaos Communication Kongress von, wie lange ist das her, mit der Rakete? Oh, die Rakete war 2011. Dann gab es noch das Radio-Batch, das gab es 2015. Das habe ich auch verpasst. Aber meine erste Erfahrung mit Löten war, es gab eine schöne Leiterplattenrakete. Da kommt dann noch ein LED-Raketenfeuer hintendran, Löten. Und das habe ich dann gemacht. Dann habe ich Löten, ich will nicht sagen, ich habe Löten gelernt. Ich habe Löten ausprobiert. Und jetzt gibt es also das Cardio, die Cardio. Die Cardio ist ein, das Cardio oder die Cardio, der Cardio? Das Cardio, das Badge. Das Badge, das Cardio-Badge. Ist ein Rechteck mit einem unfassbar kleinen Bildschirm drauf. Und bunten Lichtern. Das sieht sehr sympathisch aus. Was ist das? Das ist ein sogenanntes Badge. Es ist ein elektronisches Gerät, das letzten Endes einen ganzen Haufen Sensoren mit sich bringt. Und eben auch eine Anzeige, ein paar Knöpfe, sodass man das auch steuern kann. Warte, gib her. Die Knöpfe habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Wo sind denn die Knöpfe? Na so kleine Druckknöpfe. Ah, da kannst du irgendwie ein Menü auswählen und so was. Vielleicht auch ausschalten, wenn du zu lange drückst und so. Und ja, das sind letzten Endes zwei Leiterplatten mit einem Mikrocontroller und einem Haufen Sensoren. Ich würde gerade sagen, das größte, naja nicht das größte, das größte sind schon die beiden Leiterplatten. Aber ich sag mal vom Volumen her am massigsten ist eigentlich der Akku, oder? Was ist dieses Ding, was dazwischen ist? Sag doch mal genau, was das kann. Ja, alles Mögliche. Also erstmal gibt es eine ganze Reihe Sensoren. Das wichtigste und sozusagen das Herzstück, genau pun intended, ist das EKG. Warte mal, ich hatte Recht mit dem Herzschlagmesser? Nicht Herzschlagmesser, EKG. Aber wir reden schon von diesem Herzding, was wir haben. Ja, ja, ja, wir werden alt. Nein, also die Hintergrundgeschichte ist da das Schneider, der quasi der Haupttragende dieses Projektes war, auch Familienhistorie mit Herzproblemen hat sozusagen. Und für ihn ist es deswegen was sehr Bescheidsames. Und er hatte halt irgendwann so eine Liste an möglichen Sensoren, die man in so einen Badge einbauen kann, gesehen und hat dann irgendwie dann stark das EKG für ihn heraus und gesagt, okay, damit machen wir was. Und das war so die Geburtsstunde des ganzen Badges. Und dann kamen von anderen Seiten auch andere Ideen und irgendwann entwickelte sich dann so im Laufe des CCC-Kongresses letztes Jahr so mit ein paar Leuten in Gesprächen eben die Idee, dass man so eine Art Armbanduhr bauen könnte. Also diese beiden Leiterplatten, dazwischen eingeklemmt der Akku, oben drauf wie gesagt der kleine Bildschirm und dann an so einem Band fest. Und das wiederum ist durch so zwei Metallstreifen gezogen. Genau, das sind für das EKG. Das sind die Kontakte fürs EKG. Genau, du kannst auch noch, da gibt es auch dann noch einen Anschluss da seitlich, so ein Lochding da. Und da kannst du dann theoretisch, also es gibt in dem Cardio Village, im Badge Village kannst du gegen eine vorgeschlagene Spende von 10 Euro auch nochmal so Elektroden kaufen und so was. Und dann auch nochmal richtig EKG messen damit, damit es noch ein bisschen präziser ist. Aber so geht das eben auch schon. Wahnsinn! Und muss man das auch selber zusammenbauen? Ja, aber das ist nicht viel. Das sind diese vier Spacer, diese Abstandshalter und die Schrauben und das Band, auf die dann diese Metall-Schnupsis da irgendwie das einklemmen. Also das Dranschrauben. Also ich mein jetzt löten. Weil bei der Rocket war ja so ein bisschen auch der Gedanke, hier kannst du auch gleich mal ein bisschen löten lernen. Genau, also hier kannst du schon auch löten. Der Gedanke hier ist auch, du kannst nähen lernen, wenn du das noch nicht kannst. Kann was lernen? Nähen. Naja, also da sind Löcher, die siehst du, ne? In dem Badge sind hier so ein paar Löcher. Oben dran sind Löcher, ja, okay. Kann man das in der Kamera sehen? Nee, das ist zu weit weg, wahrscheinlich nicht. Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber wenn man sich das so anschaut, da sind eben so Löcher und da sind so sogenannte GPIOs, also Pins, die man digital schalten kann. Und da kann man zum Beispiel mit leitendem Faden, den wir auch im Badge Village haben, kann man dann aufs Armband noch so LEDs nähen und so und dann über die Badge schalten. Eine andere Sache, die mich an dem Ding noch total begeistert, ist der Bildschirm. Klar, wenn man sich jetzt eine Smartwatch kauft, dann ist das auch ein sehr kleines elektronisches Gerät, dafür, dass es so klein ist, der großen Bildschirm. Aber das Ding, das ist so groß wie ein Daumennagel, aber wie viele Pixel sind da drauf? Moment. Man kann vier Zeilen Schrift sehr deutlich lesen. Das steht hier, glaube ich, gerade gar nicht drauf. Ach, 80x160. 80x160. Ist das jetzt so ein State-of-the-Art-Bildschirm oder ist Technologie mittlerweile so weit, dass man sagt, ja so ein kleiner Chip, der dir irgendwie... So ein Partikel ist nicht so besonders. Das ist halt der Bildschirm, der da noch draufpasste und ins Budget passte. Also wenn du so eine Apple Watch hast, da kostet einfach der Bildschirm unglaublich viel Geld. Also das wollte ich fragen, das ist ein Budget-Teil. Ja klar, alles ist Budget. Wir haben auch Sponsoren für die Sensoren gehabt und für den Mikrocontroller. Sonst hätten wir das zu dem Preis gar nicht machen können. Es sind so zwei Komponenten. Das eine ist natürlich die Hackbarkeit. Deswegen wollten wir kein Gehäuse vorgeben, damit du es selber verändern kannst, damit du da dein eigenes Ding bauen kannst. Das ist überhaupt ein unglaublich wichtiges Thema, über das ich gleich nochmal reden möchte. Das andere ist natürlich auch, dass du ein gewisses Budget hast, was das Ding kosten soll. Wenn du davon 5.000 Stück produzierst und diese Watch-Hersteller 100.000 oder Millionen, dann musst du einfach in einem bestimmten Rahmen bleiben. Ich würde gerne gleich nochmal drüber sprechen wollen. Ich habe die Idee, mir ein Stück Hardware zu bauen. Und dann mache ich das in einer 100.000, aber schon vierstädtigen Stückzahl, wie das geht. Aber du hattest gerade noch erzählt zum Selbstbauen? Na ja, also die Idee dahinter, vielleicht fange ich nochmal kurz bei der Genese des ganzen Projektes an. Okay, ganz von vorne. Nein, nicht ganz von vorne. Die Idee dahinter war, wir machen das mit diesen EKG-Sensoren und so weiter. Warte mal, stopp. Also die Idee am Anfang war, wir wollen ein Device, das EKG kann und dass man das nicht so teuer ist und dass man sich rumtragen kann. Genau. Und dann sind wir natürlich drauf gekommen und haben drüber nachgedacht. Und was das Problem bei diesen ganzen Fitness-Trackern sind, die du so kaufen kannst in Smartwatches, ist, dass es keine gibt, wo du vollständig in die Rohdaten rankommst. Wo du einfach selber hacken kannst, bauen kannst und die vollständige Kontrolle über deine Daten hat. Diese ganzen Fitbits und sowas laden halt die Daten irgendwie in die Cloud hoch oder du kommst da nicht in die Rohdaten ran und du hast da einfach keine Kontrolle über deine Daten. Und hier hast du halt absolute Kontrolle, sowohl über die Software als auch über die Hardware. Und das ist halt unglaublich wichtig, dass es so ein Gerät überhaupt gibt, damit man da selber weitermachen kann. Also ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass jemand sagt, das ist großartig und das ist auch nicht so teuer. Und wir haben jetzt diese Hardware und können die auch nochmal nachproduzieren und vielleicht noch ein bisschen modifizieren. Aber wir haben hier schon mal einen Anfang, um dann irgendwas Sinnvolles weiteres zu bauen zum Beispiel. Dafür ist es da, dafür ist es alles Open Source. Das heißt, es gibt davon auch die Schaltpläne? Natürlich. Und jetzt ist das ja... Also ich meine, ich trage eigentlich total ungern Uhren, weil es eigentlich fast keine Uhren gibt, die nicht gleichzeitig auch ein Statement sind. Das ist ja auch ein Statement. Genau, das ist auch ein Statement. Ist das sozusagen so groß und ich sag mal für eine Uhr halt klobig, weil es dann billig ist? Oder geht es einfach nicht kleiner? Naja, es geht schon alles immer kleiner. Aber das hat dann auch sehr viel mit sehr langen Entwicklungsprozessen zu tun. Prototypenbau, was kannst du machen und wie kannst du es dann überhaupt noch reparieren und hacken? So die Apple Watch, wenn du die reparierst, in Anführungsstrichen, dann tauschst du da eine Platine aus und fertig. Hier kannst du halt, wir haben hier Leute sitzen, die mit kaputten Uhren, denen wir kaputte Cardio Badges geben und die dann die einzelnen Bauteile auslöten und neu löten und reparieren. Das geht aber schon für Profis. Das sind natürlich schon Leute, die das möglicherweise auch beruflich machen oder zumindest wahnsinnig gut löten können. Aber wir können das selber tun. Das ist halt auch noch mal so ein Aspekt, also die Reparierbarkeit von diesem Ding. Du kannst mit entsprechend Wissen technisch hingehen und sagen, das Display ist kaputt, dann hol ich mir ein neues oder bestelle es irgendwo und mache es selber und nicht irgendwie, ich muss in den nächsten Apple Store rein. Und dann wird das halt einfach weggeschmissen und fertig. Das ganze Ding weggeschmissen, dir neu gegeben, fertig. Das würde ich jetzt aber gerne wissen wollen, weil das finde ich auch faszinierend daran, dieser Prozess, also ich vermute an dem Projekt haben Leute mitgemacht, die haben Ahnung und wissen halt eh, wie das geht. Aber trotzdem ist das ja im Prinzip ein Smart-Hardware-Produkt, also im Sinne von es ist klein und man kann es am Körper tragen, dass eben als privat mehr oder weniger produziert worden ist. Genau, ja. Wie macht man das? Also ich sozusagen gerne wirklich detailliert im Sinne von, ich habe jetzt eine Idee und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich Software, da kann ich mir irgendwie Schaltpläne, irgendwie zurecht denken, aber was für Schritte gibt es alles bis vor, dass so ein Ding ist, wo man sagt, dabei stelle ich jetzt 5000 Stück von. Wer muss da noch mit vorkommen? Also ich will ganz kurz mal meine Rolle in diesem Projekt erklären, weil dann mache ich mich selber so ein bisschen frei von, der hat ja keine Ahnung. Also ich habe in diesem Projekt vor allem Outreach gemacht, das heißt Gruppen herangeführt an das Projekt oder Leute herangeführt an das Projekt, die wir in irgendeiner Form, deren Wissen wir gebrauchen konnten. Zum Beispiel gibt es eine Gruppe namens Koba Kant, die uns ganz doll mit diesen Armbändern geholfen hat und die einfach elektronische Textilien irgendwie Erfahrung hat. Dann gibt es ganz viele und das war die eine Rolle. Dann habe ich so ein bisschen im Projektmanagement mitgeholfen. Das heißt, ich habe selber jetzt keine Schaltpläne gezeichnet oder Firmware geschrieben oder sowas. Aber du weißt, welche Schritte es waren, die du nicht gemacht hast? Genau, ich weiß ungefähr die Schritte. Und wenn ich einen vergessen habe, dann möge man... Einfach laut rufen, das kriegen wir auch noch runter. Ja, also du fängst natürlich erstmal an und suchst dir ungefähr die Bauteile raus, die du brauchst. Also einen Prozessor, der das leisten kann, was du haben willst. Die Sensoren, die du drauf haben willst. Und dann fängst du... Also nur um auch meine Position in diesem ganzen Ding zu erklären. Ich sehe hier dieses kleine Ding, das sozusagen sehr faszinierend ist. Und habe so... Ich hab manchmal so einen Moment, wo ich so denke, oh krass, die Technologie schreitet immer weiter fort und manchmal kriegt man es gar nicht mit. Deswegen stelle ich manchmal jetzt auch solche Fragen wie dir zum Beispiel. Wenn du sagst, Bauteile aussuchen, heißt das in dieser Größenordnung? Habe ich die Auswahl? Und nehme nicht einfach das, was da ist? Also teils, teils. Wir hatten natürlich Beziehungen zu Hardware-Herstellern, die wir gefragt haben, habt ihr Lust uns durch Sponsoring auszuhelfen? Und wenn ja, was habt ihr denn für Bauteile, die möglicherweise bei uns reinpassen würden? Da gibt es eine kleine Liste, da kann man sagen, ok, EKG wäre geil, Blutsauerstoffmessgerät wäre geil, Atmosphärensensor wäre geil. Und dann sagt man, ok, das muss hier alles irgendwie mit drauf. Und dann fängt man an, erstmal grundsätzlich zu überlegen, die haben eine bestimmte Größe. Man nimmt eine Software, zum Beispiel Keycard, das ist eben eine CAD-Software, speziell für so Leiterplattengeneration. Und da setzt man dann erstmal ganz blind die Bauteile drauf, sodass man ungefähr so die Größenordnung hat. Was muss da alles drauf? Stellt dann zum Beispiel in dem ersten Workshop, den wir hatten, haben wir festgestellt, ok, es wird zwei Leiterplatten benötigen, um das ganze Ding sinnvoll zu machen. Dann überlegt man sich, wie sollte eigentlich dieses mechanische Design überhaupt sein, damit man grundsätzlich fragen kann, ok, wir haben jetzt das Armbandmuster ja dran, das heißt, wir müssen das irgendwie befestigen, wir müssen diese beiden Leiterplatten, wie wollen wir dann die miteinander verbinden, wie soll das irgendwie halbwegs robust sein, was muss da geschraubt werden, solche Geschichten. So, und dann fühlt man das so langsam zusammen. Und dann hat man irgendwann so ein grobes Bild von, ok, wir haben jetzt zwei Leiterplatten, wir haben diese Sonsoen, die müssen so und so platziert sein, man muss den optischen Sensor oben auf die Leiterplatte drauf anbringen, weil unten drunter sieht er ja nichts, und man will aber das EKG irgendwie an einer bestimmten Stelle haben und man will die LEDs oben natürlich auch anbringen, weil unten drunter sieht man sie nicht. Und daraus ergibt sich dann so ein grobes Muster und dann fängt man das erstmal an grob zu designen und wenn man dann entsprechend weit genug ist, dann kommen einerseits die ganzen nötigen Bauteile, zum Beispiel Widerstände, Kondensatoren, Spannungsregler und was man eben alles sonst noch so braucht, um die Stromflüsse irgendwie geregelt dadurch zu bekommen. Und dann fängt man an eben die Leiterbahnen zu ziehen in dieser CAD-Software, um das alles irgendwie, damit da letzten Endes ein gescheiter Stromkreis entsteht. Kann man das auch in dieser Software dann gleich, also kann dir das auch simulieren, was dann passiert? Kann Kiko das simulieren? Ich glaube nicht. Okay, irgendwann baut man es zum ersten Mal und wenn man dann Mist gebaut hat, dann... Ja, also man schaut sich das dann ordentlich an und im Zweifelsfall ganz viele Augen im Prinzip. Und hat das dann so designt und kommt dann so an den Punkt, wo man dann sagen kann, okay, das ist jetzt an so einem Status, wo wir jetzt erstmal alles drauf haben, wo wir glauben, dass die Leiterbahnen richtig funktionieren, dass alles richtig korrekt angeschlossen ist. Und dann bestellt man einfach mal so eine Leiterplatte. Wie bestellt? Na, es gibt Produzenten von Leiterplatten. Und denen sagt man dann, okay, wir brauchen jetzt hier, keine Ahnung, zehn Prototypen Stück und dann gibt man denen Geld und dann produzieren die das. In Handarbeit oder gibt es da Maschinen für? Also da gibt es Maschinen für, die das, ich weiß nicht genau, wie da so der kommerzielle Leiterplatten-Herstellprozess ist, aber die werden da halt hergestellt und dann geschickt. Und dann lötet man im Zweifelsfall die ganzen Bauteile, die man schon mal irgendwie als Muster hat. Warte, stopp. Wenn Leiterplatten hergestellt werden, meinst du, das sind dann die Platten mit den Löchern und den Leiterbahnen, aber keine Bauteile drauf? Genau. Dazu kommen wir später. Das nennt sich dann Bestücker. Das ist dann später. Also erstmal nur die Leiterbahnen. Und dann fängt man an und lötet das noch selber drauf in diesem Stadion. Das kann man natürlich bei 5000 Stück nicht mehr leisten, dazu kommen wir dann aber später. Und dann hat man eben diesen Prototypen und hat da irgendwie alles ordentlich draufgelötet. Und dann fängt man an, das durchzutesten mit Oszillatoren und Multimetern und allen möglichen anderen Dingen. Und stellt dann irgendwie fest, okay, das sollte jetzt irgendwie so halbwegs alles stimmen. Und man macht 10, weil man sich auch mal verlötet? Nee, weil auch verschiedene Leute sich damit dann schon auseinandersetzen müssen. Optimalerweise hat man von dieser Art und Weise mehrere Zyklen. Man produziert den ersten Prototypen, stellt fest, dass man das gegen schief. Warte, ich will noch kurz fragen. Der erste Prototyp, ist der schon auch genau so groß? Oder gibt man dann sozusagen, weil es billiger ist, macht man es doppelt so groß und dann kann man einfach erlöten? Also in der kommerziellen, ich weiß nicht, das gab mal von der Zeit so einen relativ langen Artikel, ich glaube, nicht als Elektroniker, als Techniker, die den Prototypen des ersten iPhones so Fotos gezeigt haben. Der war halt so groß wie so ein A4-Blatt ungefähr. Wo dann wirklich die ganzen Bauteile einfach da drauf waren und dann konnte man schön irgendwie Sachen machen und das sah man alles und so weiter und so fort. Das ist natürlich in so einer, da gibt es dann schon entsprechende Boards und entsprechende Zwischenstadien, wo man vielleicht auch einfach mal einen Sensor an einen Controller anschließt und schaut, wie so was geht. Aber letzten Endes kommt dann irgendwann, ab irgendeinem Punkt muss es natürlich diesen Prototypen geben. Wir hatten in diesem Fall jetzt nur einen. Wir hatten nicht die Zeit, noch einen zweiten oder sogar einen dritten Zyklus zu machen. Mehrere Prototypen, aber nur einen Durchgang? Genau, also einen Durchgang. Und dann kommt der an und dann baut man das auf und schaut, dass irgendwie alles soweit funktioniert und stellt fest, hier und da ist ein Fehler. Dann fixt man das eben in der CAD-Software und lässt dann nochmal viel mehr Leute drüber schauen und schaut sich das an und dann kommt man dazu. Und dann hat hoffentlich der Prototyp auch schon den Status, wo er dann schon benutzbar ist für solche Sachen wie Firmware. Also wo dann das Betriebssystem von dieser Uhr schon geschrieben werden kann, an die entsprechenden Sachen angeschlossen werden kann und so weiter. Muss man das von Anfang an selber schreiben zum Betriebssystem oder gibt es da auch Bauteile? Nein, es gibt da schon Bauteile, aber du hast natürlich zum Beispiel, die muss dann entsprechend die Treiber für bestimmte Sensoren anpassen auf das Betriebssystem für das Chip und so weiter. Aber es ist sozusagen ein Zusammenstecken von Dingen, die da sind, also zusammenstecken und verändern und anpassen und nicht so sehr einfach einen Grund auf selber schreiben? Größtenteils, soweit ich das weiß. Jetzt bewege ich mich aber schon echt ins Ungewisse. Also ich sehe noch keine entsetzten Gesichter, ist das richtig? So, super. Da geht der Daumen nach oben, jetzt ist alles gut. Sollte ich die Ohren binden, dann könntest du ferngesteuert Stromschocks bekommen. Ich glaube, wir haben keinen ausreichend starken Spannungsgeneral. Dann hast du einerseits die Prototypen, die jetzt auch möglich sind, in unseren Prozess durch ganz Deutschland gewandelt, sodass verschiedene Hacker-Spaces schon welche hatten. So dass man sagen kann, ich habe jetzt Lust, Teil X für die Firmware zu entwickeln oder ich brauche schon mal das Bluetooth-Modul, um das grundsätzlich mit der Android-App zu verbinden. Dann gab es in Berlin einen Prototypen, an dem man schon mal ein bisschen was machen konnte. In München gab es einen, in Bremen gab es einen usw. Dann geht aber der Produktionsprozess dann so richtig in die Vollen. Dann ist man irgendwann dabei, dass man sagt, das ist jetzt hoffentlich alles soweit gut, es haben genug Leute drüber geschaut, wir können jetzt anfangen, diese Hardware zu produzieren. Ich will mal kurz noch eine Sache fragen, bis zu dem Punkt, wo wir hier sind. Mal abgesehen davon, dass da wahrscheinlich unfassbar viel Zeit reingeht. Von welchen Kosten reden wir? Also dieses Bauteile kaufen und jemanden beauftragen diese Leiterplatten zu machen. Ist das sowas, wo man sagt, naja, wenn irgendwie so ambitionierte Hobbyfotografen geben, halt auch irgendwie Geld aus, das relevant ist, ist das eher so? Oder ist es eher, man denkt eigentlich fast schon lieber drüber nach, eine kleine Firma zu gründen? Oder ist es nur Peanuts? Also ich kann, ich weiß es nicht so genau, aber was ich sagen kann, ist halt, dass man sich diese Badge, also die gab es nicht einfach kostenlos zum Ticket dazu, sondern die Bitte war eben 20 Euro dafür zu geben. Und das ist so die Größenordnung dessen, was so die Hardware plus solche Sachen wie Reisekosten von Schneider zum Beispiel, der halt dann regelmäßig in Berlin bei unserem Bestücker war und irgendwie sonstige Meetings hatte. Und ich glaube, das ist auch da in dieses Budget mit reingeflossen. Und das Armband und alle möglichen anderen Kosten eben, dass das auch noch mit drin ist. So, das muss natürlich, gehört noch dazu. Aber Arbeitszeit wurde natürlich nicht bezahlt, außer von den Dienstleistern, die wir eben bezahlt haben. Und dann ist der Schaltplan sozusagen alles fertig. Wenn man das auch durchgetestet, dann kann man so ein bisschen ans Design gehen, sagen, wir haben jetzt irgendwie drei, ne vier verschiedene Farben für die obere Leiterplatte. Das ist eine lila, blau, schwarz, grün, dann kann man hier noch ein bisschen designen. Also obendrauf sind so ein paar Raketen und steht ein Cardio. Und dann unten drunter steht noch irgendwie kein Herz für Nazis und politische Aktionen.
Kann man einen Applaus haben?
Und Chaos Communication Camp, dann designen wir das noch, macht das schön. Dann haben wir mit dem Designer, der auch diese wundervolle... Worüber gab es mehr Schreit? Ob der Code effizient genug ist oder ob das Design schön genug ist? Ach, ich glaube, in dem Team hat man sich über weder noch gestritten. Es waren alle froh, dass Code erst mal gemacht wurde und dass Leute mithelfen. Und da gab es auch sehr wenig bis gar keinen Streit drüber. Soweit ich weiß vielleicht. Ich habe jetzt keine Kamera und Video und Dinge in jedem Hacker-Space. Vielleicht haben sich da Leute unterhalten. In meinem Kopf war noch gerade die Vorstellung, sozusagen eine Gruppe von Menschen baut dieses technisch versierte Projekt und rockt das bis zu dem Punkt, wo es hier sein ist. Nein, die Leiterplatte muss blau sein, nein, grün. Von Judea. Nein, überhaupt nicht. Wir hatten von Grund auf die Idee, mehrere Farben zu machen, haben uns ein bisschen abgestimmt, was die Farben sein sollen, haben auch nochmal auf Twitter gefragt, was für Armbandfarben Leute gut finden. Und es hat auch nochmal mehrere. Und alle waren ziemlich froh, dass der Designer, der eben das Camp-Logo und das Camp-Design gemacht hat, auch involviert war und uns früh helfen konnte und damit gemacht hat, sodass das Design vorne drauf ist von ihm quasi. Da hat er uns mitgeholfen und dann war es das. Und dann hat man eben erst mal dieses fertige Ding. Und dann fängt man an zu bestellen. Warte mal, ich versuche mal zu prophezeien, wie das dann läuft. Du hast erzählt, ihr habt Bauteile aus verschiedenen Quellen, teilweise von Sponsoren, teilweise gekauft. Ich habe schon gehört, es gibt etwas, das ein Bestücker ist, also vermutlich eine Firma, die... Das heißt, die Leiterplatte wird bei einer anderen Firma gemacht, wird auch extra angeliefert. Dann geht man mit allem zu diesem Bestücker und sagt, hier, bau das mal zusammen, oder wie läuft das? Also, wenn du ein kommerzielles Ding hast, wo du nicht später mit Hochdruck dieses Ding für das Camp produzieren musst, wo es nicht so schlimm ist, wenn es eine Woche später kommt, dann machst du optimalerweise das bei einem Unternehmen in Shenzhen, in China, wo dann irgendwie alles aufeinander kommt. Dann sagst du, diese Bauteile kauft ihr einen, da ist die Leiterplatten-Design, so bestückt ihr das, danke, schickt mal rüber. Das Problem dabei ist, wenn da irgendwas schief geht, wenn da eine Verzögerung kommt und das Ding dann irgendwie im Zoll hängt, dann kommt es halt nicht an und dann ist das Camp vorbei. Deswegen haben wir größtenteils das Ganze in Deutschland oder teilweise in Europa, ich glaube, alles in Deutschland fertigen lassen. Das heißt, wir haben die Bauteile in China bestellt bei Importeuren, teilweise eben von den Sponsoren liefern lassen, teilweise eben von Dienstleistern, die dann in China sitzen und das in großen Mengen bestellen können, zum Teil auch in Shops, die in Deutschland existieren. Je nachdem, was wir brauchten, haben das dann entsprechend, je nachdem, noch mal in entsprechende Formate gepackt, die dann zum Bestücker kommen, also Gurte und so. Das muss ja in einer bestimmten Form aus der Maschine laufen. Also es gibt ja eine Bestückungsmaschine? Genau. Wie so ein Munitionsgurt, kommt da so eine Bauteil-Dings an?
Genau.
Und dann bestellst du halt die Leiterplatte bei dem einen Dienstleister und sagst dem anderen Dienstleister zum Bestücken, hier folgende Bauteile kommen an dem Tag an, die Leiterplatten kommen an dem Tag an, wir brauchen hier folgende Termine usw. Du machst es dann natürlich wie üblich, holst dir Angebote ein usw. Und dann läuft die Logistik los. Und dann kommt es irgendwann eben bei dem Bestücker an und der bestückt das Ganze und dann schickt er es zu uns. Und wir haben dann z.B. die Displays noch alle. Also das war echt krass. Da tiefsten Respekt, dass z.B. die gesamten Displays letzten Endes im X-Hind Hackspace in Berlin aufgelötet wurden. Was? Unter anderem, und das ist das wirklich geile, es kam ein Mensch, der nicht auf dem Camp ist, also auch keinen Badge kriegt und trotzdem richtig volle Kanne mitgeholfen hat, einfach nur weil er Bock hatte. Und dann kommt das hier an. Und dann sind es halt ganz viele noch Bauteile und so und alles. Dann sind wir jetzt schon quasi am Camp. Die Teile kommen an, die Firmware wird langsam fertig. Es ist Tag Null, es ist immer noch nicht, also ganz viele Sensoren kann man noch nicht anstellen, zumindest nicht über MicroPython, zu dem Thema komme ich nachher noch. Und dann sitzen die einen im Zelt in Hochdruck und machen die Firmware fertig. Und die anderen setzen da schon mal so, wir haben da so Papiertütchen gekauft, also das war zum Beispiel auch ein Statement, das wir machen wollten. Früher gab es Plastiktüten, jetzt gibt es Papier. Und dann gibt es halt so eine ganze Crew von Leuten, die da irgendwie Sachen in Tüten schmeißen und diese Flyer dazu stecken und so. Und dann geht eine große Orgie am Flaschen los, das heißt, die ganze Firmware muss ja noch auf das Ding. Das heißt, sitzen dann Leute da mit so 8-fach USB-Hubs, die irgendwie diese Firmware dann noch auf dieses Ding kriegen. Ist es dann wenigstens so, dass wenn die Firmware einmal fertig ist, dass man die Geräte nur ansteckt, aufspielen, absteckt? Oder gibt es dann auch noch sozusagen... Es gibt Updates die ganze Zeit. Immer noch. Das meine ich nicht. Was habt ihr gesagt? 5000 Stück? Es gibt ja immer das Ideal, dass Computer deterministische Maschinen sind. Das heißt, wenn es bei einem funktioniert, funktioniert es bei allen anderen 4999 auch. Größtenteils. Es gab natürlich schon einen ganzen Haufen Boards, die dann erstmal in eine Kaputtkiste geschmissen wurden. Die gingen dann ins zweite Zelt. Da sitzen ein paar Leute, die richtig geil löten können. Und die haben dann sich dahingesetzt und angefangen zu reparieren, reparieren, reparieren. Dann werden diese Dinger geflasht mit Version 1.1 der Firmware. Inzwischen sind wir bei Version 1.7. Und die kann man dann selber updaten. Warte mal, das war vor vier Tagen? Okay. Habt ihr noch was anderes gemacht? Also, manche sind wirklich die gesamte Zeit auf Hochdampf. Ich hab jetzt, musst du geben, ich hab jetzt auf dem Camp nicht mehr so viel gemacht. Ich hab ein nettes Python-Script geschrieben, mich noch ein bisschen. Und dann kümmere ich mich immer noch so drauf, dass ab und zu ein bisschen Essen im Zelt ist. Und so, aber... Nicht vergessen, essen. Ja, und dann wird es geflasht. So, und wenn man jetzt irgendwie das Betriebssystem updaten will, dann steckt man das einfach an seinen Rechner, dann kommt so ein Messenspeicher-Dings, und dann lädst du das ZIP-File runter, entpackst es und schiebst die Dateien drauf, rebootest das Teil und dann ist die neue Firmware drauf. Und dann gibt es halt, also, dann, die Firmware ist natürlich der Teil, der dauernd geupdatet wird, und dann gibt es aber so die sogenannte Hatchery, da kann man dann eben Python-Dateien runterladen, die da oben drauflaufen. Also der App Store quasi? Der App Store, genau. Es gibt halt, also das war halt, also es gab so ein paar Sachen, die uns relativ wichtig waren bei diesem Batch, nachdem das letzte Batch, das Radio-Batch ziemlich geil war, aber schon relativ nerdy. Das war halt ein Software-Defined Radio, also ein digitales Funkgerät. Damit können einige HackerInnen hier schon ordentlich was anfangen, ein paar so ein bisschen was, aber ganz viele einfach auch nicht. Und die Idee war, dass wir hier etwas bauen, womit wirklich einfach jeder und jeder hier irgendwie, wo sie eine Idee davon haben, was das bringen könnte. Wo man mit Spaß haben kann, dass man, was nicht nur blinkt, sondern wo man Nutzen von haben kann. Und dazu gehört natürlich auch, dass man es dann relativ vielleicht programmieren können sollte. Und dann fällt so C als hardwarenaher Sprache irgendwie raus, weil C ist dann schon relativ komplex und kompliziert. Und deswegen gibt es hier drauf MicroPython. Das ist eben eine Version von Python für Mikrocontroller. Und das ist relativ einfach. Aber wir reden schon noch von der Liga, man muss programmieren können. Ja, aber man kann damit relativ schnell programmieren lernen. Aha, okay. Also um eine Idee hier drauf binden zu lassen, sind zwei Zeilen Code. Und ein kleines Beispiel, sogar ein Booklet mit Code. Das erinnert mich an früher, als Computerspiele Zeit trifften, Computerspiele als Listing abgedruckt haben. Ja, so ähnlich. Und am Anfang waren halt auch noch nicht alle Sensoren da über MicroPython verfügbar. Das heißt, man konnte schon mit dem EKG reden, aber nur mit C und jetzt kann man das inzwischen auch mit MicroPython. Das heißt, man kann sich das Ding selber bauen. Und das Coole ist, es sind weit über 100 verschiedene Eggs in der Hatchery bzw. Apps im App Store. Wir haben während des Camps Leute über 100 Dinge gebaut, die von lustig blinken, über Sensoren anzeigen, über verschiedene Uhrendinger und Nickname anzeigen in verschiedenen Versionen und alles Mögliche kann man sich im Runterladen anschauen und ist geil. Ist da schon was passiert, was dich überrascht hat? Also wie gesagt, what the fuck, das habt ihr mit unserem Ding gemacht? Naja, irgendjemand hat damit geduscht. Okay, ich meinte jetzt eigentlich, wer ein Programm geschrieben hat, aber okay, hat es das überstanden? Nein, natürlich nicht. Aber das war auch schon sehr what the fuck. Zugegeben. Aber ich meinte, ob jemand mit dem, mit dem, eine technische... Schon klar, also, ähm, ich muss sagen, ich hab einfach noch nicht so richtig die Zeit gehabt, da durchzuscrollen. Es gibt schon ein paar ganz coole Sachen. Es gibt relativ viele Dinge, diese ganze LED-Reihe. Weiß nicht, ob der POV, Persistence of Vision, was sagt. Das ist so diese Idee, wenn du so LEDs ganz schnell bewegt vor deinem Auge, dann zeichnen die so ein Bild, wenn du die unterschiedlich schnell ansteuerst. Damit gibt es relativ viele coole Sachen. Man kann sich jetzt irgendwie so ein Bitmap-File hochladen und das irgendwie in die Luft wedeln und dann anzeigen. Und das finde ich ganz cool. Die ganzen Sensoren, das ist natürlich eigentlich das Spannende. Sag doch mal, was da drin ist. Ich lasse mich mal ganz kurz den Flyer hier, dann vergesse ich auch keinen. Also Positionssensor mit Magnetometer. Beschleunigung. Stopp, halt. Du musst das so sagen, dass jeder weiß, was das ist. Positionssensor, da kann ich mir noch was vorstellen. Was macht dein Magnetometer? Na, das Magnetfeld der Erde entsprechend ausmessen. Auslesen Kompass. Aber in verschiedene Richtungen, soweit ich weiß. Accelerator, also Beschleunigungs-Sensor. Umweltsensor für Temperatur, Feuchtigkeit und Luftdruck. Da hat jemand, glaube ich, soweit ich weiß, irgendwie so ein Ding gebaut, das anhand des Barometers feststellt, wie hoch du es geworfen hast. Macht man das vor oder nach dem Duschen? Bluetooth Low Energy, also du kannst das Ding über Bluetooth, es gibt eine Companion App für Android und iPhone. Das heißt, du kannst irgendwie App installieren, kannst das Ding auch teilweise über App steuern, kannst auch zum Beispiel die ganzen Sensordaten auslesen oder solltest du es zumindest irgendwann können. Und kannst es damit verbinden und läuft halt über Bluetooth Low Energy. Ursprünglich einer der Träume, die wir am Anfang hatten, war auch, dass es so ein Netzwerk gibt, damit die Uhren so untereinander miteinander reden können. Das haben wir dann leider... Später? Ja, klar, wenn das Leute bauen wollen, sehr, sehr gerne. Aber wir kamen dann letzten Endes dann doch nicht so richtig hinzu. Aber das ist auch nicht so schlimm. Also die Sachen, die wir uns eigentlich vorgestellt haben, grundsätzlich sind wir jetzt auch schon sehr, sehr weit. Und natürlich ist sowas auch nie fertig. Das ist irgendwas von Blutsauerstoff? Ich dachte eigentlich, wir hätten auch ein Blutsauerstoffmesser. Ich bin mir jetzt aber gerade nicht so sicher, ob wir den wirklich haben. Der ist drauf, danke. Wie geht das? Ach so, das ist der Lichtsensor. Der macht halt überall Infrarot. Da legt man seinen Finger drauf und dann weiß der, wie viel Blutsauerstoff man hat. Crazy Shit. Ich hab zu diesem ganzen medizinischen Ding noch zwei Fragen. Das erste hat mal irgendjemand mit einem anderen Gerät gegengetestet, wie zuverlässig die Daten sind, die da rausfallen? Na, das ist schon so ein richtig kommerzieller EKG-Sensor. Das mag ja sein, aber hat das mal jemand getestet? Diese Dinger sind halt auch in anderen, also in deiner Apple Watch ist kein anderer Sensor drin. Das mag ja sein, aber hat das mal jemand getestet? Also ja, die Bauteile, die ihr verbaut habt, sind die selben. Er sagt gerade, das ist schon getestet worden. Das andere ist im Zert. Komm doch einfach mal vor, wenn du so viel darüber weißt. Sehr gut, geh mal dahin, da ist noch ein Mikrofon.
Genau, dann muss dich das Mikrofon ran.
Du hast Uhren gefahren und weißt dir viel darüber?
Ja, es hieß dann so, da liegen noch 1080 Stück irgendwo rum in Deutschland und du fährst doch eh von München hoch, dann nimm noch welche mit. Weil man musste ja irgendwie zum Camp. Es kamen dann immer noch so ein paar Batches und wir saßen dann auch teilweise beim Rausbrechen der Plantinen da und haben die dann glattgefallen, damit man sich nicht die Arme verletzt.
Das hab ich vergessen, das war jetzt nicht gelag.
Das war...
So, und jetzt, du meinest, irgendwer hat das getestet?
Also ich weiß, dass jemand mit seinem Gerät beim Zert war und hat es dann mit dem profiziellen EKG-System von dem, von dem, wie geht es jetzt?
Also Zert sind die Mediziner auf dem... Erdgeist hat heute getötet, warum niemand die Health Angel eigentlich nennt. Egal.
Und die haben wir also jetzt gegengecheckt und gesagt, passt schon.
Okay, passt schon. Es gab auch, muss ich ganz kurz hinhaken, das Zert hat auch bei uns einen Workshop gemacht dazu. Wie man damit umgeht, oder was? Und es gibt überhaupt ziemlich großartige Workshops bei uns, von Dingannähen bis zu eben EKG und Co. Man kann sich das anschauen. Ich glaube, wenn es nicht im Wiki ist, dann an dem Zelt von unserem Badge Village. Aber für alle, die jetzt das Chaosradio als Podcast hören und sich fragen, das ist ja schön, dass ihr auf dem Camp das alles gemacht habt. Aber was ist mit uns? Na, ihr habt dann ja eh nicht einen Badge, weil ihr... Warum nicht? Weil ihr... Na ja, nein, was ich sagen will, es gibt ja leider bisher die Badges, nur für die Teilnehmerinnen des Camps. Vielleicht hätten wir das mal mal erklären sollen, oder? Also, dieses Ding ist für die Teilnehmer des Camps gemacht worden?
Punkt.
Punkt, aber...
Aber?
Du kannst natürlich jederzeit die Schematta runterladen und die Bauteile-Liste und dir so ein Ding selber bauen. Oder, wenn du jetzt irgendwie wirklich Bock drauf hast, das ganze Ding natürlich irgendwie aufsetzen als hier Crowdfunding, ich möchte hier mal 2000 Stück herstellen und verteile die dann für alle und so. Da bist du frei drin, weil es ist Open Source. Ja, es kollidiert bei mir gerade zwischen, das Ding soll dafür da sein, dass man möglichst einfach damit auch programmieren, lernen kann und hey, bau dir doch einfach ein selber, wenn du Bock hast. Ja, aber wir können jetzt nicht als Badge-Team das leisten, das Ding zu produzieren. Aber wenn du das möchtest, dann bist du eingeladen, da selber zu produzieren und zu vertreiben. Zweitkarriere? Zweitkarriere vielleicht? Ich glaube dafür ist, hier sehen Sie meine beiden linken Hände. Aber das heißt, ihr habt dieses Projekt auch jetzt gemacht für das Camp und danach Schluss? Naja, was heißt danach Schluss? Also hoffentlich machen weiter Leute Dinge damit und hacken damit weiter. Und dann gibt es ja wieder den Kongress. Und dann gibt es vielleicht irgendwie da nochmal ein paar Workshops, wo Leute Sachen vorstellen, die sie damit gemacht haben. Von der Rocket-Batch von vor acht Jahren ist das Repository und das Wiki immer noch so ein bisschen aktiv. Und da wird immer noch ein bisschen was gemacht. Und hier und da setzt sich dann nochmal eine Gruppe irgendwo in einem Hackspace hin und baut nochmal so ein Abend irgendwie noch irgendwas da dran. Und das ist cool. Das ist ja auch der Gedanke dahinter. Und theoretisch wäre natürlich super, wenn da irgendjemand nochmal mehr macht oder so. Das wird dann sicher ein bisschen teurer, weil es diesmal dann keine Sponsoren gibt. Aber das könnt ihr natürlich schon tun. Meine Güte, mein haben wir Reflex ist gerade sehr hoch. Na gut. Aber ich bin trotzdem ein bisschen, sozusagen, also nicht schockiert, aber verwundert, dass man... Aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen der Style an das Camp oder in den Kongressen, dass es diese Projekte gibt, die dann für die diesmal am Ende sind. Also was ich mich frage ist, wenn ich so ein Ding bauen würde, was so komplex und schön ist, dann zu sagen, okay, das war's jetzt, bye, wir machen nix aus Canada, das fände ich... Naja, ich mein, also kennst du dieses Telefon von Amazon, das die mal gebaut haben, dieses Kindle-Phone, Fire-Phone? Ich glaub, da haben sie weniger verkauft als 5000. Im Ernst jetzt, also wir haben ja schon eine ordentliche Stückzahl da draußen. Und das sind ja auch alles, in der Entführungsstunde, die Zielgruppe. Also das sind ja auch größtenteils Leute, die damit auch wirklich was anfangen können und da das weiterentwickeln können. Das ist ja schon mal ein geiler Anfang. Also falls irgendeiner von euch jetzt hier im Publikum vor Ort oder an den Podcasts endgerät, den der Schlussfass dieses Ding noch mal nachzuprotehren, sagt mir Bescheid. So, haben wir noch was vergessen? Alles drin? Wir wissen jetzt genug über das Badge, dass wir auch eins haben wollen. Verstehe. Ich glaube, ja, also ich hab auch alle meine Sachen, die ich so loswerden wollte, was uns wirklich wichtig ist, was wir auch gesagt haben wollten, irgendwie los. Ich möchte noch mal explizit den Helden und Heldinnen im Badge Village danken. Da gibt es einfach übermenschliche Leistungen. Ganz großartig. Und allen, die damit geholfen haben, aber auch die Leute, die die Hatchery irgendwie befüllen mit geilen Apps und sowas, super. Und ich bin auch echt gespannt zu sehen, dann hinterher vielleicht noch mal im Wiki nachzulesen, was alles passiert ist und was danach noch kommt. Das wird schon ganz ordentlich, glaube ich. Das ist sehr, sehr geil. Das ist euer Applaus. Wenn es dem genannten Publikum noch eine Frage, das meine ich genau so, eine Frage gibt, dann wäre jetzt noch kurz Gelegenheit zu. Nein, wir haben wirklich alles gesagt. Philipp, Julian, vielen. Dank. Jetzt gehen wir von ganz klein, passt ans Handgelenk, zu ganz groß. Dafür braucht man Schienen, sonst geht die Welt kaputt. Herzlich willkommen die Schienenfahrzeuge. Das sind Sebi und ein unbekannter weiterer Mann, der gleich seinen Namen sagen wird. Ihr dürft auch auf die Bühne klatschen, nicht nur runter. Das ist okay.
So, Mati ist mein Name.
Mati, hi Mati. Hi Sebi, Sebi, oder?
Ja, genau.
So, zwei Menschen, zwei Fahrzeuge. Vor mir stehen, ich fasse es mal grob zusammen, zwei Platten mit Sitzbänken drauf.
Sehr gut zusammengefasst.
Aber es ist anscheinend eine der technischen Bastelhöhepunkte des Camps. In meinem Vorbereitungsdokument, was mir zur Sendung bereicht wurde, steht Schienenfahrzeuge.
Ja, also es gibt hier Schienen. Es ist ein Ziegeleigelände, auf den die früher mit den Loren ihre ganzen Lehm und Ziegel transportiert haben. Und es gibt einen Rundkurs. Und vor vier Jahren haben wir uns halt gedacht, das nutzen wir und haben halt angefangen, Schienenfahrzeuge zu bauen, mit denen man Transpersonen einmal ums Gelände fahren kann.
Weil es geht?
Weil es geht, genau. Und letztes Jahr gab es drei Fahrzeuge. Und dieses Jahr sind wir bei Hamburg, Essen.
Warte mal, ist das wie bei den ICEs? Die Dinger haben Namen?
Nein, das sind die Spaces, wo sie herkommen. Wo kommt das Card her?
Das ist von den Münsteranern.
Und Bochum, wir haben drei mitgebracht.
Angeber?
Also sind wir bei sechs Fahrzeugen, die mitgebracht worden, was schon mal ganz gut ist.
Was wird denn mitgemacht? Wettrennen oder Karnevalsumzüge?
Kinderbespaßung, hauptsächlich Kinderbespaßung.
Genau, schön bunt soll es ja auch sein.
Was ist die Herausforderung der Ansage? Also, ich habe das Gefühl, wenig Dinge, die einfach sind. Ich vermute, wenn es einfach wäre, würde man es nicht machen.
Also ich habe da durchaus den einfacheren Weg genommen. Ich habe halt ein paar Hoverboard-Teile zusammengeschraubt. Hoverboard-Teile.
Also quasi die Sex-Says ohne Stange, wo man sich so drauf stellt?
Die meine Pool fahren in den Videos.
Die kriegt man ja recht günstig gebraucht.
Weil sie Pool waren?
Nee, dann wären sie auch nicht mehr zu benutzen. Aber davon habe ich mir ein paar besorgt. Gebraucht, gekauft, möglichst günstig, aber noch funktional. Und bin dann halt hingegangen und habe da eine andere Firmware draufgeflashed, die man auf GitHub findet. Das ist relativ einfach im Vergleich zu selber bauen. Dann hat man tatsächlich einen ganzen Antriebsstrang in diesem Hoverboard drin, der eigentlich schon funktioniert. Da muss man halt die Kabel ein bisschen länger machen und vielleicht noch ein paar andere Hürden nehmen. Aber tatsächlich war es mir so relativ einfach möglich, ein Schienenfahrzeug zu konstruieren an der Stelle.
Du hast also Hoverboards an ein Brett geschraubt, und die Räder waren dann zufällig so weit auseinander, dass sie auf die Schienen passen?
Leider nein, so einfach habe ich es mir nicht gemacht. Die Schienen, die Räder sind tatsächlich verstellbar. Ich kann auf verschiedenen Breiten fahren, weil wir haben hier ein Gelände, wo wir drei verschiedene Spurbreiten haben. Und es war ja nicht klar in der Planungsphase, welche Spur jetzt frei sein wird. Und tatsächlich kann ich die Räder so verstellen, auseinander schieben und so. Von den Hoverboards ist unten drunter eigentlich nur das Rad mit dem Motor drin und die Metall-Funk.
Die Motoren sind in den Rädern drin?
Ja, das sind so genannte Brushless-Motoren. Deswegen brauchen die auch eine spezielle Ansteuerung, um die ich mich nicht kümmern wollte. Deswegen habe ich die Controller oder die Elektronik aus den Hoverboards genommen und mit einer neuen Software versehen, um das Problem von denen lösen zu lassen.
Ich komme ja aus Berlin. Die S-Bahn ist ja so semi-zuverlässig. Wie weit kannst du die Rede auseinanderziehen?
Also, ich habe mal einen Meter gemacht, das geht auch. Es wurde niemals auf Straßenbahnschienen in Essen getestet, das wäre ja illegal.
Aber wenn es getestet worden wäre, was wäre das Ergebnis gewesen?
Dass es durchaus funktional gewesen wäre. Der Pernis war natürlich ohne Motor, keiner wollte den Führerschein verlieren. Und tatsächlich gibt es auch Pläne, das auf Normalspur umzurüsten, so dass der DB vielleicht ein bisschen...
Warte mal, dass ihr zum nächsten Camp sozusagen auf diesen Dingern kommt?
Wenn die Akkus das aushalten, warum nicht? Das wäre ja ganz praktisch.
Das wäre tatsächlich meine nächste Frage gewesen. Also schon alleine war es als draufgebaut. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schwerer als so ein Hoverboard, wenn dann auch noch irgendwie... Also das Ding ist ja was? Zwei Mal einen Meter, also ganz grob und dann vier Stühle drauf. Dann können also auch vier Leute da drauf sitzen. Und das sind was? Zwei Hoverboards oder?
Genau, also das hat auch tatsächlich so ein bisschen Probleme gemacht. Wir haben das alles immer brav mit zwei Leuten getestet. Zwei Hoverboards, funktioniert super. Wir haben damit Kilometer abgerissen ohne Ende. Und dann kommen wir hier aufs Camp und bauen dann das erste Mal die Stühle drauf. Und auf einmal reichen die Akkus noch eine Runde und streiken halt ständig. Und ja, als wir das dann so ein bisschen getestet haben, haben wir halt als Lösung gefunden, halt vier Hoverboardbatterien zusammenzuschalten, also quasi die mit doppelt so viel Power zu versorgen. Und damit schaffen wir halt ein bisschen mehr als eine Runde. Und wir haben tatsächlich auch schon fünf Leute darauf fahren lassen, dass halten tatsächlich die Teile, die von den Hoverboards übrig geblieben sind, noch aus. Das sagt der Chinesen nicht gerne, aber tatsächlich sind die Teile, die wir drangelassen haben, über das, was auf der Verpackung steht, belastbar. Also so 250 Kilo pro Rad geht. Also man muss auch sagen, ich hab's extra. Es gibt da bei der Firmware, die man draufflescht, die man auf GitHub findet, gibt's einige Tricks, um die schneller zu machen. Und Leute sagen immer, mach schneller, mach schneller. Und ich so, lass mal, ich möchte keine Umfälle erzeugen. Und bei den Geschwindigkeiten, ich mach so 12, 5 kmh maximal, das ist, wir hatten keine Probleme bei irgendwelchen Umfällen. Der ist so ein paar Zentimeter. Also dadurch, dass ich halt wirklich dem Controller sage, du musst jetzt stehen bleiben, geht der halt wirklich in die Eisen quasi. Und das rüttelt die Leute dann auf dem Brett schon gut durch. Nee, nee, aber vorne eine Stange, wo man sich festhalten kann.
Also ist es nur ein Drehzweig? Da sind doch bestimmt auch bunte Lichter und Spielereien.
Also es ist mehr so eine Spielplattform natürlich. Also es gibt einen Knopf in der Schaltung, dann fängt es an zu steuern. Deswegen hab ich da auch schon mal ein paar...
Wie zu steuern?
Ja genau, dann kann es lenken.
Auf Schienen lenken? Ich bin irritiert.
Ja genau, man baut dann halt andere Räder drunter, das ist vorgesehen. Und dann kann ich tatsächlich so auf der Straße damit fahren. Das ist halt so ein Long-Term-Use-Case. Obendrauf kann man nicht nur diese wunderbaren Stühle drauf machen, sondern auch eine Hängematte. Da bin ich heute den Tag mit rumgefahren, vielleicht haben das einige Leute gesehen. Und dann hat es vorne dran eine sehr, sehr helle Lampe. Die hat ein Freund von mir gebaut, die ist so hell, wir können sie eigentlich nicht benutzen. Deswegen ist noch eine kleinere Lampe daneben. Und um auch nachts fahren zu dürfen, haben wir dann brav einmal rundherum sogenannte Schranklampen dran gemacht, die man so bei verschiedenen Online-Hintlern findet, um halt bunt blinkend oder passend zu den Vorschriften halt fahren zu können. Die Vorschriften ist halt so bei Schienenfahrzeugen, vorne weiß, drei Stück und hinten zwei rot. So das können die oder halt bunt blinken.
Aber wo du jetzt sagst, das geht auch ohne Schienen, dann muss ja auch eine Lenkung irgendwie drin sein.
Genau, die kann ich einschalten. Da gibt es so einen Knopf und dann kann ich mit der Nunchuck, also das Ganze wird über eine Nunchuck gesteuert.
Muss man kurz sagen, Nunchuck von der Wii, der eine Teil des Controllers, wo so ein kleiner Joystick und so paar Tasten raus sind.
Genau, genau.
Aber wo kommt die Steuerung her? Ist auch Teil des Hoover Boards oder wie wird gelenkt?
Genau, also die Wii steckt halt oder der Controller ist halt an so einem Arduino dran, das ist ja so ein kleiner Mikrocontroller und der gibt dann tatsächlich das Signal weiter an die Controller und die machen das halt dann, das kriegen die halt in verständlicher Form beigebracht.
Okay, jetzt hast du mir erklärt, wie das Signal dorthin kommt, wo die Lenkung stattfindet, aber wie passiert die Lenkung? Ist es so, dass das linke Rad nicht langsamer dreht als das rechte und dadurch kommt eine Drehung zustande dazu?
Genau, so eine Panzerlenkung, die nennt man tatsächlich so, dass man halt links langsamer fährt als rechts und dann eben halt dadurch die Kurve beschreibt.
Herr Sebi, ist das die Zukunft der Stadtmobilität, die Sie da gerade entfernen? Ich wünschte es mir. Also wenn ich jetzt so dran denke, so richtig weit entfernt von einem Tuk-Tuk, also in Asien, diese dreirädigen Dinger, ist es jetzt eigentlich nicht mehr. Wenn du jetzt sagst, eine Runde, was ist das in Kilometern?
Ich glaube 1, 8 Kilometer.
Ja, okay, ist vielleicht noch Verbesserung.
Ja, natürlich.
Aber wie groß sind diese Akkus?
Das sind tatsächlich die original Hoverboard-Akkus. Die sind nicht so groß.
Das heißt, man könnte sozusagen noch einen kleinen kleinen Kisten dran, ein bisschen dicker, dann kämen wir mal weiter.
Wir hatten großartige Leute bei uns, oder wir haben großartige Leute bei uns im Airfahrer und die hatten halt richtig, richtige Batterien gebaut für ihre Longboards und anderen Fahrzeuge so, die mir auch super geholfen haben bei diesem Projekt. Und mit deren Batterien komme ich vier, fünf Runden lang hier um den Kurs drumherum. Und mit ordentlichen Batterien geht da deutlich mehr. Aber es war natürlich auch so ein bisschen Teil der Challenge, so erstes Fahrzeug, man möchte nicht alles neu kaufen, man guckt erst mal, was man aus dem Alten Neues machen kann.
Okay, also ich stelle jetzt diese Frage und sage gleichzeitig, du hast angefangen, ja du wusstest ganz genau, was Schienenfahrzeuge für leuchtenden und vorn und hinterher müssen. Was glaubst du, würde der TÜV zu diesem Fahrzeug sagen?
Ich glaube, er würde sehr emotional schreien und wegrennen.
Na gut, aber das ist ja immer die erste Reaktion, wenn man was hat, was sozusagen nicht ans Motorrad gehört. Was würde dann passieren? Also jetzt nur mal rein spekulativ, meinst du, man könnte so ein Ding bauen, was sozusagen mehr als eine Bastelei ist, sondern tatsächlich zumindest einer theoretischen Vorstellung von Sicherheit genügt?
Also das ist auf jeden Fall möglich, gerade wenn ich jetzt so in die aktuelle politische Lage von solchen Fahrzeugen halt reingehe, sieht das gerade sehr düster aus. Man muss halt eine Typenzulassung bekommen, um halt sein Fahrzeug überhaupt offiziell auf deutschen Straßen fahren zu dürfen. Es muss sehr starken Regulatorien standhalten und das ist eigentlich außerhalb von möglich. Gerade die Typenzulassung, die dann einen höheren Betrag kostet, ist sehr schwierig. Also dann braucht man es einmal zulassen, aber das ist dann halt für die ganze Serie. Wenn man jetzt nur einmal ein kreatives Fahrzeug bauen möchte, weil man halt ein paar Hoverboards gefunden hat, dann sieht das schlicht aus. Und ich würde mir da tatsächlich wünschen, dass die Politik mit ihren Gesetzen eigentlich bessere Vorgaben gemacht hätte.
Aber ich kann den Impuls total verstehen, aber es ist andererseits auch eine praktikable Vorstellung, dass jemand zum TÜV geht und sagt, ich habe ja was gebaut, kannst du mal gucken, ob das sicher ist, und die das dann in einer Zeit hinbekommen, wo man dann sozusagen nicht den Monatsgehalt hinlegen muss.
Das passiert ja tatsächlich sehr viel im Motorradbereich, dass die Leute sich Fahrzeuge zusammenbauen und zum TÜV gehen und sagen, hallo, geht das?
Wie, aber wo ist die Schranke dann? Wenn es mehr als vier Räder sind, wird es komplizierter, oder? Bitte? Wo ist denn die Schranke? Weil du sagst ja gerade, das geht hier anscheinend nicht.
Wieso geht es bei Motorrädern? Das geht hier nicht, weil ich hier eine Typenzulassung brauche.
Aber warum? Also was ist der Unterschied zu dem Motorrad?
Die Gesetze. Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich...
Aber das Gesetz muss ja irgendwo den Unterschied machen zwischen dem Motorrad und deinem Ding. Sind es die vier Räder oder?
Dass es elektrisch angetrieben ist. Es würde halt unter die Neuordnung der Elektromobilität oder so fallen. Und damit hättest du halt ein ganz, ganz großes Problem, weil es ist erstmal Typenzulassung teuer. Und ich müsste dann halt auch so was wie eine mechanische Bremse an beiden Rädern anweisen.
Warte mal, aber wenn du das Ding mit einem Dieselmotor gebaut hättest, wärs einfacher?
Ja, dann wäre das richtig.
Das andere Modell, ich nenne es liebevoll das Modell Sperrholz.
Exakt, also wir haben sehr, sehr viel Holz.
Was ist daran anders, außer die Holzbänke?
Also wir haben uns vor vier Jahren gedacht, boah, hier gibt es Schienen, hier wird es ganz viele Leute geben, die Schienenfahrzeuge bauen. Wir bauen das mit dem wenigsten Budget. Und wir haben vor vier Jahren mit 25 Euro Budget angetreten und haben damit ein Fahrzeug gebaut, das hier fünf Runden über den Kurs geschafft hat.
War das die Challenge? Fünf Runden, erst dann darf es auseinanderfallen?
Nee, wir mussten es zwischendurch immer wieder zusammenbauen. Am Ende fuhr es, glaube ich, sogar drei Runden halbwegs durch. Aber die ersten zwei Runden waren sehr, sehr mühsam. Und dieses Mal haben wir auch gesagt, 25 Euro, ich habe einen Baumarktgutschein bekommen zum Geburtstag. Wir mussten jetzt leider für 20 Euro ein Zahnrad kaufen, um unseren Motor anzuflanschen. Und jetzt sind wir bei 32 oder 35 Euro gelandet. Und der Baumarktgutschein ist nicht ganz aufgebraucht, weil wir haben nicht mehr Schrauben gekauft. Und der Rest ist irgendwoher zusammengesucht.
Okay, ist der Antrieb derselbe? Also auch mit Superbotting? Oder wenn du jetzt gerade sagst, großes Zahnrad kaufen?
Genau, also wir hatten beim letzten Mal einen Rollstuhlmotor, den wir einfach außen an unseren Achsen drangeflanscht haben. Und jetzt haben wir einen Gleichstrommotor von einem kleinen Elektroauto genommen. Und wir haben also keine Hoverboard-Motoren. Wir haben Holzräder, wir haben also kein Gummi oder Stahl. Und wir haben Holz genommen. Und beim letzten Mal bestanden die komplett aus Holz. Und die sind jetzt kaputt gegangen in den Runden, weil das war nicht so die gute Idee für diese Querkräfte.
Was sind Querkräfte?
Wenn ich in die Kurve fahre, fährt man ja mit dem Auto erst mal geradeaus und die Schienen halten einen in der Spur. Optimal ist es so, dass gute Zügekonische Räder haben und dann so in den Schienen hin und her pendeln. Jetzt sind hier aber die Kurven so stark, dass die diese Grenze außen drum haben, wie es auch bei der Eisenbahn ist.
Das sieht so geradeaus wie ein Teller.
Genau, und dieser Rand ist der Spurkranz. Den haben wir jetzt aus alten Bremsscheiben von einem Solarkar-Projekt genommen, die ihre Bremsen einmal blau gefahren haben und die wegwerfen wollten und das funktioniert jetzt tadellos. Wir sind sehr zufrieden.
Aber wie übertragt er die Kraft vom Motor auf die Räder?
Das habe ich noch nicht ganz verstanden. Genau, also der Motor hat eine Kette und das hat es auf die Achse von diesem Auto mit einem Kettenantrieb übertragen und da ist jetzt wie beim Fahrrad so eine Kette dran und dann wird das auf die hintere Achse übertragen.
Und hinten dran ist noch so ein riesiges schwarzes Ding. Was ist das?
Das ist unser Vereinslogo, das ist vor vier Jahren fertig geworden und dann musste das natürlich auch an den Zug und ich mag keine Veränderungen, also musste es dieses Jahr auch wieder an den Zug.
Warte mal, das andere ist nur ein PR-Stand, weil ihr im Prinzip ein verhaarendes Vereinslogo gemacht habt?
Genau.
Wie schnell ist euer?
Ich habe mich mal getraut, 20 kmh hier auf der Strecke zu fahren, aber über 15 möchte man nicht fahren. Das ist so rumpelig hier auf diesen Schienen und also das ist okay.
Ihr habt vorne auch keine so eine Festhalte-Stange?
Nee, also vorne sitzen keine Kinder alleine und am liebsten gar keine Kinder, aber mit den 10 kmh, die man so fährt, ist das schon okay.
Jetzt sehe ich unter der Sitzbank ist eine Zweiturnfahrenfahrer.
Genau, die haben wir aus, wir waren mal in der Ukraine und dort brauchten wir ein bisschen mehr Kraft in der Hupe und mussten uns das auf so einen Markt kaufen und die ist da runtergelandet. Die benutzen wir im Notfall, die ist ziemlich laut, die nervt schon ordentlich. Okay, was gibt es noch für an Spielereien? Also die Hupe hat zum Beispiel das Problem, dass die läuft auf 12 Volt, unser Akku ist auf 27 Volt und jetzt haben wir so Klingeldraht vom Feldtelefon genommen, weil die so viel Leistung brauchte, dass wir keinen DC-DC-Wandler gefunden haben, um die Spannung anzupassen und jetzt fällt an der Leitung, die wir genommen haben, der Rest ab.
Okay, aber heißt das, man kann jetzt sozusagen auch so Glühkunst machen an der Leitung?
Die Hupe ist ja immer in der Regel sehr, sehr kurz an, das geht alles schon. Die liegt ja auch im Freien, ist jetzt nicht unser Problem, was wir haben. Ein größeres Problem haben wir unser Controller zu dem Motor, passt nicht zu dem Motor und wir mussten denen so Spulen vorgaukeln und jetzt sind unter der Sitzbank so ein paar Lampen, die gehen dann an und ja, ich habe von dem Auto, mit dem ich hier hingefahren bin, die Lampe auch geopfert, die ist dann in der ersten Runde durchgebrannt und jetzt haben wir Lampen von den Flipper genommen und die aneinander getüppelt und das funktioniert ganz gut.
Also die Dinge, die du da von den Klingeldrähten und Lampen erzählst, zusammen damit das Ding aus Holz gebaut, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Ich würde lieber mit dem anderen fahren, glaube ich.
Ja, aber dafür haben wir den etwas größeren Akku gefunden. Wir schaffen zehn Runden.
Falls ihr euch heute Nacht hier auf dem Camp fragt, was dieser Feuerschein ist, der immer wieder in eurem Zelt vorbei ist, müsst ihr jetzt Bescheid. So, jetzt habt ihr beide gesagt, was die Geschwindigkeiten sind, die man damit fahren möchte. Ich würde jetzt gerne wissen, wie viel die Dinger maximal hinkriegen, wenn man sie treibt.
Wie gesagt, ich habe mich nicht schneller als 20 getraut.
Da bedarf es doch sicherlich einer aus Vorwissen genährten Schätzung, wie hoch man das Ding treiben kann.
Das ist ein Gleichstrommotor, den ich so verschalten kann, dass der unendlich hoch dreht, aber irgendwann fehlt die Leistung. Und es muss nur lange genug geradeaus gehen und dann fährt man, weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung, 40, aber ist auch nur geschätzt.
Also es gibt in der Firmware so ein paar Schalter, die ich nicht umgelegt habe, weil durchaus andere Leute dann so was wie ja weit über 35 kmh mit geschafft haben. Und solange das noch aus Holz ist und so diese Form hat und keine Anstallgurte, lasse ich das mal lieber sein.
Aber habt ihr nicht so übernacht, die Fernbedienung mal zu machen? Aber die andere Frage, die ich gerade bei den Hoover Boards haben wollte, hast du ja immer von Firmware, also von außen sieht das dann im Teilfall schön einfach aus, schließt man das Gerät irgendwo an und spielt was auf. Aber das sind ja Produkte mit Technik drin, wo jetzt eigentlich erstmal nicht vorgesehen ist, dass man diese Firmware austauscht. War das schwierig? Also musste man da irgendwie Aufwand betreiben oder ist das so, man macht das Ding auf, dann ist da irgendwo so ein versteckter USB-Port und dann geht es automatisch?
Also man muss da schon ein bisschen dran rumlöten. Da sind so ein paar Pinne dran, wo erstmal ein paar Konnektoren drauf angelötet werden müssen. Dann muss man das wunderbare Tool des Mikrocontroller-Herstellers verstehen und sich die Firmware auch selbst kompilieren. Und da ist schon Aufwand drin. Also es gibt da auch durchaus bessere Software inzwischen auf GitHub, auf die ich jetzt gerade nicht setze, weil mir gerade die Zeit fehlt, mich damit zu beschäftigen. Und ich habe eine stabile Firmware drauf. Ich bin ganz glücklich so. Da ist man schon einen Abend dran, bis man verstanden hat, wie das so geht.
Das ist eher weil das so obskur ist, nicht weil die absichtlich da Dinge verschlüsseln oder schwierig machen.
Was der Chips-Hersteller per Default macht, ist, wenn du da sagst, ich möchte gerne Software auf diesen Mikrocontroller aufspielen, löscht der erstmal alles. Das bedeutet, ich kann das nie wieder zu Hoverboards zurückbauen, außer es gibt natürlich ein GitHub, das die Hoverboard-Software neu implementiert hat. Es geht dann schon dank Leute im Open-Source-Bereich. Aber nicht desto trotz löscht sich dann einfach mal die Software. Meine erste Idee war, lass mal hier schon mal beschreibbar machen, den Controller gucken, ob das geht. Und dann fahre ich noch eine Runde mit dem Hoverboard, bei dem fehlte ja dann die Software. Also da rechnet man jetzt auch nicht mit so.
Okay, na schön, das klingt doch alles sehr posierlich. Was ist denn heute Ferz? Es macht Licht nachts, glaube ich. Was sind das dann für... Habt ihr schon sozusagen die Pläne für das nächste Jahr? Fürs nächste Camp, meine ich.
Also bei uns ist der Plan, das Ding erst mal wieder vier Jahre sicher einzulagern und zu hoffen, dass das nicht jemand zersägt im Hacker-Space und dass wir alles wieder neu machen müssen. Das ist unsere Herausforderung, die Teile wieder über vier Jahre zu retten. Vielleicht gibt es mal einen Anhänger.
Das wollte ich gerade fragen. Wenn man schon auf Schienen fährt, muss man nicht so...
Also es gab natürlich niemals die Versuche, hier irgendwas übers Gelände zu ziehen. Das muss man sich dementieren. Und bei mir ist tatsächlich der Plan, das auf dem Kongress dann als normales Straßenfahrzeug mitzunehmen. Und ja, in vier Jahren, ich hoffe dann nicht so weit, dass ich das nicht mehr mit Holz bauen muss, sondern vielleicht ein paar robustere Materialien benutzen kann.
3D-gedruckte Rennzugverkleidung.
Irgendwie sowas.
Also liebe Leute, das Podcast hört für euch gleich nicht, aber wenn man euch heute noch auf den Camp drückt, darf man mal Probe fahren? Dann Gesichter merken und ansprechen. Vielen Dank, dass ihr hier wart und eure Schienenfahrzeuge vorgestellt habt. So, apropos Schienenfahrzeuge. Ganz logischerweise machen wir jetzt als nächstes etwas mit einem Bahnhof zu tun. Ist der Daniel schon hier? Das wäre ganz hervorragend. Er ist natürlich hinter dem Schienenfahrzeug. Herzlich willkommen. Daniel Domscheit-Berg aus dem Verschwörbarenhof. Bitte nehmen Sie Platz vor dem Mikrofon. So, jetzt haben wir schon zwei Takes lang drüber geredet, wie man Technik baut. Und dann ist ja das Camp irgendwann zu Ende. Dann werfen wir das alles weg. Bzw. wir stehen vor der Herausforderung, das vier Jahre lang einlagern zu müssen. Ihr habt ein Recycling-Projekt. Ihr habt ein Projekt, das mit Recycling zu tun hat und Technik.
Na, wir sind da, versteht man mich? Oder wie ist das mit dem Stand? Du musst dicht ans Mikrofon gehen. Sei Whitney Houston General. Ja, also erstmal, wir sind der Versteh-Bahnhof, nicht der Verschwör-Bahnhof. Es gibt das Verschwör-Haus, wir sind in Ulm und wir sind alle beide Jugend-Hack-Labs. Und all diese Orte mit kreativen Wortspielen als Namen, das ist ja eh alles kompliziert.
Also was nochmal, Versteh-Bahnhof in Ulm und der Versteh-Bahnhof in Fürstenbergen-Havel.
Vielleicht kennt ihr das, das ist zwei Bahnstationen von hier. Also wenn man den Grandsee in den Zug steigt.
Mit den Dingern oder mit dem richtigen Zug?
Nee, wäre auch interessant. Wir haben ein stillgelegtes Hausgleis gerade. Vielleicht könnte man da eine Sonderstrecke einrichten. Das wäre ja auch mal ganz interessant. Aber wir sind hier drüben, genau gegenüber in diesem Zelt. Da haben wir ein bisschen Workshop-Gedöns mitgebracht. Und dann hat sich das mit dieser Recycling-Sache eigentlich mehr so zufällig ergeben. Das ist nicht unser Projekt, sondern das ist eigentlich die Idee von Laser Max. Der ist glaube ich gerade gar nicht da. Aber der hatte im Wiki irgendwo eingetragen, dass er so eine Dismantling-Station bauen will, wo man also hinkommen kann mit Elektroschrott, also irgendwelche Geräte, die dann auseinandergenommen werden. Dann können die ausgeschlachtet werden, zum Beispiel für diverse Schmuckprojekte hier für Basteleien mit irgendwelchen Schrottrobotern oder so. Und der Rest würde eben in eine geordnete Entsorgung laufen, sodass diese Ressourcen, die da drinstecken, eben auch weiterverwertet werden und das nicht irgendwo im gelben Sack landet oder was auch immer Leute so machen, wenn sie Plastik haben, wo irgendwas drin ist, was weggeworfen werden muss. Und ich hatte das im Wiki gelesen und wir steuern eigentlich jetzt... Ich dachte gerade, irgendwas hat hier vibriert. Das ist das Kerl, das kam von da drüben.
Wir müssen uns auch keine Sorgen machen.
Erst wenn zu dem Hupen noch die Trampel in den Hufe kommen, dann sprühe ich auch. Wir hatten das gelesen und dann habe ich ein bisschen Hardware mitgebracht in Absprache mit ihm, dass wir das ein bisschen anschieben können. Das hat dann so eine Dynamik entwickelt hier, die nicht ganz geplant war, aber die total interessant ist.
Dass sehr viele Leute festgestellt haben, ich habe noch immer dieses alte Handy, was seit Monaten in meinem Rucksack vor sich hingammelt oder wie?
Ich glaube in der Tat. Wir haben ein paar Laptops bekommen und es gibt auch zwei, drei andere Dinge, die abgegeben wurden, aber mehr so Kleinkram. Von daher war es schon mal gut, dass wir etwas mitgebracht haben, weil das für genug Action da drüben gesorgt hat. Der Hintergrund da ist, vielleicht erinnert sich da auch irgendjemand dran, es gab 2012 hier in Berlin, im Kontext von Freifunk und dem Club, so ein Projekt, das nannte sich Freedom Fighter Box. Das war damals was, wo wir so ein bisschen auf die Störerhaftung aufmerksam machen wollten. Und es gab aus einer Firmeninsolvenz zwei Paletten oder so, als original verpackte WLAN-Router, die Open-WRT-kompatibel waren. Und dann hat Mirko aus Berlin für diese Kisten ein Image gebaut. Und wir haben einen VPN-Tunnel nach Schweden zu ePredator konfiguriert. Und die dann hier...
Oh, also kurz so erklärt das auch die Leute, die nicht wissen, was ich da sporte.
Genau, also wir haben auf diesen Router einen VPN-Tunnel konfiguriert, mit dem man dann quasi übers Ausland surft. Und so konnten wir uns diese rechtlichen Problematik hier mit der Störerhaftung in Deutschland technisch entziehen. Und dann haben wir 200 dieser Router oder so in Berlin in verschiedenen Bars und Cafés und sowas verteilt. Und wollten so ein bisschen auf diese Störerhaftungsproblematik aufmerksam machen. Und von dieser Aktion, es gibt ein paar, außer mir auch noch andere Leidtragende, die seitdem viele große Kartons mit originalverpackten Routern, die wir damals nicht losgeworden sind, noch irgendwo im Keller stehen haben. Und ich dachte dann, vielleicht ist das eine gute Gelegenheit, die einfach hierher zu bringen. Ich hab sie ja auch nicht so weit. Dann wären die endlich weg. Dann bin ich hier mit 120 Routern oder so eingeritten. Wir haben die da vorne hingestellt.
In der Hoffnung, dass sich noch jemand mitnimmt, damit was anfangen kann?
Ich suche ja seit 2013 Leute, die damit noch was anfangen wollen. Es waren noch sehr viele Leute in den letzten Tagen an unserem Stand und fragten, was macht ihr da? Wir sagen dann, wir haben hier originalverpackte Router, die noch nie genutzt wurden. Und führen sie der Verschrottung zu. Und dann die Hälfte der Menschen sagt, habt ihr sie noch alle? Da kann man bestimmt noch irgendwas mit machen. Und bis auf zwei Gespräche, in denen sich dann wirklich was ergeben hat, was noch damit gemacht wird, haben nach 10 Minuten spätestens eigentlich alle aufgegeben, weil dann man an irgendeine Grenze kommt. Die haben 4 MB Speicher, da macht auch jetzt das Open-WRT-Image nicht besonders viel Spaß. Es hat auch seit 2013 keiner mehr eine Firmware gebaut für den Chip, der da drin ist. Es hat 100 MB Ports. Es gibt eine ADSL2, ADSL2 Plus wird unterstützt. Alle haben jetzt langsam VDSL oder sowas. Es ist nicht schön, würde man sagen. Wir haben jetzt einen Menschen getroffen, die hier in der Tat von irgendjemand anderem ein DSLAM bekommen haben, also die DSL Gegenstelle, die dazu kompatibel ist und die jetzt 10 dieser Router mitgenommen haben, um die in ein Bergwerk auszurollen, damit man dann im Bergwerk Telefonkabel verteilen kann und mit dem DSLAM dann ein kleines DSL-Netzwerk aufbaut, damit in verschiedenen Räumen dieses Bergwerks oder irgendwelchen Stollen WLAN vorhanden ist.
Was passiert in diesem Bergwerk?
Die wollen da Sensoren deployen und so, aber es ist halt wirklich schon ein bisschen schwierigen, einen Use-Case zu finden.
Und deswegen baut man die einfach auseinander und führt sie dem Riss halt gezogen?
Ja, genau, dann dachten wir...
Aber warte mal, du hast jetzt gerade gesagt, da sind da Leute angekommen und haben ihre Technik abgegeben. Das heißt, die Leute, die die Technik auseinanderbauen, die Leute, die die Technik abbringen, sind nicht dieselben?
Nee, das ist ganz unterschiedlich. Wir sind ja mit jungen Leuten primär am Arbeiten. Wir hatten in den ersten Tagen ein paar der jungen Leute, die allgemein auf dem Camp waren bei uns drüben. Seit gestern sind jetzt auch ein paar von den Kids, die hier aus der Gegend kommen, also Fürstenberg, Gransee und so, hier auch mit auf dem Camp fürs Wochenende, mit denen wir im Bahnhof arbeiten. Und alle, wenn zwischendrin, es gibt auch hier so drei Leute aus Costa Rica, die kamen auch schon vorbei, die sind auch hier auf dem Camp. Der eine von denen, der baut gerne Hardware auseinander, so als Mindfulness-Tätigkeit oder sowas, also der entspannt dabei, das macht er zu Hause wohl auch, und der kommt auch regelmäßig mal rüber, baut ein paar Routen auseinander, trennt das Weiße vom schwarzen Plastik, baut die Platine raus, nimmt die Spule von der Platine und trennt, soweit wir trennen können.
Aber vielleicht kannst du das ein bisschen genau erklären. Wenn man jetzt denkt, hey voll gut, das mache ich jetzt auch zu Hause, wie entsorgt man denn eigentlich Elektronik, sagen wir mal, halbwegs sinnvoll? Weil wir meinen, das ist nicht einfach irgendwie wegschmeißen, was muss man eigentlich machen, wie baut man es auseinander, wonach sortiert man, wo geht es dann hin?
Ja, also da bin ich jetzt nicht ganz der Experte, also ich hoffe, ich habe da viel gelernt jetzt von Lasermax, der sich damit halt ein bisschen intensiver auseinandersetzt. Und ich glaube, dass das erste Problem an dieser Stelle ist, dass es, also es wurde gestern glaube ich hier auf dieser Bühne ja auch ein bisschen besprochen, wie das ist mit Elektrogeräten und dann so einem Verwertungsprozentsatz oder so, der erfüllt werden muss, wie das dann im Verhältnis ist mit Sachen, die man aber selbst gebaut hat, die in all diesen Statistiken wieder gar nicht auftrauchen. Also das ist ja alles sehr kompliziert. Im Idealfall ist es so, dass dieses Gerät auseinandergebaut wird, dass mit dem Plastik irgendwas passiert, dann so grobe Bauteile, also Buchsen zum Beispiel, Schalter, auch Spulen oder so offensichtliche Materialien, also Spule aus Kupfer ist jetzt sehr einfach weiter zu verwerten, dass das eben runtergebaut wird oder runtergebrochen wird und dass dann am Ende dieses Prozesses eine Platine übrig bleibt, die eben mit SMD-Bauteilen, irgendwelchen Chips, ICs oder was auch immer einen relativen Wert darstellt. Also du hast diese Platine, die aus die Leiterbahnen beinhaltet und auf der irgendwelche kleineren Bauteile sind, die dann wieder irgendwo zermahlen wird. Also daraus wird ein Staub gemacht. Und das wiederum kommt dann in verschiedene Bäder, zum Beispiel Säurebäder oder so was, in denen dann über Elektrolyseverfahren bestimmte Rohstoffe extrahiert werden.
Das kann man aber nicht bei euch am Stand machen.
Nee, das kann man nicht bei uns am Stand machen. Wir haben das höchste Gefühl, bei uns ist der Plastik-Schredder. Der also Sorten rein weißes und schwarzes Plastik-Schreddert. Und selbst wenn man das dann macht, da kommen so Pellets raus, fragt man sich eigentlich ganz ehrlich, wie viel wirklich sehr, sehr kleines Plastik dabei auch entsteht. Was jetzt vielleicht noch nicht Mikroplastik ist, was aber durchaus in diesem Gelände hier, zumindest in kleinen Mengen, auch in die Umwelt geraten muss, wenn man da einen Schredder betreibt. Also das lässt sich so rein überhaupt nicht abbilden. Und wir haben das zu Demozwecken mal gemacht, aber der Schredder läuft jetzt auch nicht die ganze Zeit. Wir haben da drüben jetzt nicht irgendwie so ein Entsorgungsproblem kreiert oder sowas. Aber eigentlich, das Plastik ist halt auch so ein Ding, das wird kleingemahlen, damit das dann in Tüten verpackt weniger Volumen einnimmt als die Gehäuse und dann halt irgendwo anders wieder weiterverwertet. Dann ist das ABS, das will jetzt auch niemand wieder extrudieren als Material für einen 3D-Drucker oder so. Ich hoffe, die meisten nutzen PLA oder so als ABS.
Jetzt hast du mich gerade verloren. Was ist das ABS und PLA und was ist der Unterschied?
Das sind unterschiedliche Kunststoffe und ABS ist also deutlich künstlicher als Kunststoff, als PLA. PLA ist auf Milchsäurebasis. Über einen langen Zeitraum verrottet das auch. ABS ist ein richtig fieser Kunststoff, der stinkt auch, wenn er gedruckt wird. Das ist ein richtiges Plastikproblem. In der Umwelt will man das nicht haben.
Man könnte aus Elektrogeräten theoretisch diesen ABS-Stoff rausextrahieren?
Nein, der ABS-Stoff ist das Gehäuse. Das ist das Einfachste. Ich mache vier Schrauben auf und habe ein weißes Gehäuse mit einer schwarzen Unterseite. Dann kann ich das in zwei Sorten reine Farben klein machen und wieder weiter verwerten. Cool wäre es natürlich, wenn wir das als Material für einen 3D-Drucker weiter verwenden könnten. Das wäre naheliegend.
Aber will man eigentlich nicht?
Ich drucke nicht mit ABS. Vielleicht gibt es noch Leute, die machen das. Ihr dürft euch gerne bei uns Palettes abholen, wenn ihr euer eigenes Filament machen wollt. Das finde ich so interessant. Ich habe mich seit einer Woche mit der Idee, das hier mitzunehmen, beschäftigt, oder 10 Tage. Seitdem fallen mir ständig Dinge auf, die eigentlich nicht so sind, wie man sich wünschen würde. Das finde ich bei dieser ganzen Erfahrung interessant. Wir haben drüben auch noch eine Kiste stehen. Da sind 10 Router drin. Die hat sogar noch diese Packbänder außen rum. Diese Kiste wurde hergestellt in Taiwan. Das steht riesig drauf. Dann wurde das quasi kartoniert für einen Großhändler. Seitdem ist das in den letzten 8 Jahren nicht ausgepackt worden oder irgendwas anderes, sondern ist nur von Taiwan über Umwege nach Schweden gelangt, von Schweden über andere Umwege irgendwann bei mir in den Keller gewandert. Dann steht das da seit vielen Jahren. Da hat man Energie und Ressourcen in Taiwan investiert, um dieses Ding zu bauen. Und wir müssen jetzt hier Menschen beschäftigen, Kinderarbeit bei uns da drüben, die das auseinandernehmen, irgendwie nur um dann die Platine an einen Hamburger Verwerter zu schicken, der dann sehr viel Energie und total krasse komplexe chemische Verfahren anwenden muss, um idealerweise möglichst viel dieser Ressourcen da wieder rauszuholen. Also da ist ja Kupfer, Silber, Gold, Palladium, was auch immer wir so irgendwie alles in diesen Chips haben drin. Und dieses ganze Ding, also die Umweltbilanz dieser Geräte in diesem Karton, ja die ist wirklich grauenhaft. Und wenn man da anfängt drüber nachzudenken, das betrifft ja jetzt nicht nur meine Kiste da. Die ganze Welt um uns herum ist voller Kram, von dem wir nicht wissen, was wir damit machen. Und lauter Kram, den auch gar keiner von uns kaufen möchte, der irgendwie produziert ist und dann Verwertungsketten durchläuft, wo er irgendwo nicht verkauft wird. Dann landet er bei irgendeinem, der es billiger raushaut, in irgendeinem Restpostenmarkt oder so. Da will das dann vielleicht auch keiner haben. Und dann geht es vielleicht ab in irgendein weniger entwickeltes Land, wo man dann irgendwie noch versucht, den Kram zu kaufen, bis es halt entweder irgendwann jemand kauft oder das vielleicht einfach wieder irgendwo verschrottet wird. Und das ist total verrückt, wenn man drüber nachdenkt, ist das so dermaßen unlogisch und so dumm, dass es, wenn man sich länger damit beschäftigt, wirklich zum Problem wird.
Also heißt das, es gibt ja unter hackern einen Spruch, den ich mehr als einmal gehört habe, ist so, ah, die ganze Welt geht vor die Hunde, irgendwas mit Archäden und Holzarbeit. Ist das sozusagen ein weiteres Argument dafür, dass man sagt, vielleicht ist das ganz sinnvoll, weil es ist nicht nur alles ganz schlimm, sondern eigentlich die ganzen Materialien, mit denen in der Digitaltechnik halt gearbeitet wird, sind außerdem noch eine riesige Sauerei?
Na ja klar, also das aber ja nichts Neues erst mal. Also dass die Ressourcen extrem knapp sind.
Aber bis jetzt war es immer so, man weiß es und man müsste mal, aber jetzt irgendwie brennt der Amazonas und man weiß nicht so genau, vielleicht ist es eh schon zu spät. Meinst du, das wird jetzt dringender und da kann man nochmal was schrauben oder da findet jetzt ein Umdenken statt?
Ich weiß nicht, der Amazonas hatte jetzt nicht direkt was damit zu tun, wie es in irgendeiner Cobaltmine oder so aussieht.
Das meinte ich nicht, aber ich meinte sozusagen, die Welt geht gefühlt ein bisschen deutlicher vor die Hunde und es ist nicht mehr eine theoretische Möglichkeit, sondern geht jetzt los.
Also ich hoffe, dass das irgendwie ja gesetzt ist. Also wir alle sollten in dem Bewusstsein heute leben, dass wir in immense Probleme reinsteuern, wenn wir nicht an allen möglichen Ecken und Enden uns mehr Mühe geben, das anzuerkennen und darauf zu reagieren. Also das geht ja keine Ahnung. Die CO2-Problematik sitzen ja auch alle gegenüber und so. Die CO2-Problematik ist das eine Ding, aber ansonsten alles, was mit unseren Ressourcen zu tun hat, mit Arbeitsbedingungen in irgendwelchen Minen und so weiter, das müsste, ich hoffe, dass zumindest hier auf dem Camp, dass jeder, der hier ist und in dieser Community existiert, dass uns das klar ist.
Aber es gibt ja manchmal einen Unterschied zwischen Klarsein und praktische Konsequenzen haben.
Naja, das ist ja der Punkt, wo es dann auch kompliziert wird. Also ich denke dann immer, wie schön wäre es, wenn ich jetzt diesen Router hätte und der Router hätte halt einen gesockelten WLAN-Chip. Und wenn ich halt jetzt mit 802, 11, B und G, zwei älteren Standards, nicht mehr klarkomme, dann tausche ich halt diesen Chip und dann hat er irgendwie ein Upgrade bekommen und hat jetzt irgendwie unterstützt den AC-Standard oder irgend sowas. Und ist damit wieder zukunftsfähig. Ich weiß auf der anderen Seite auch, dass das nicht ist, wie Hardware funktioniert. Und dass es da ja ganz viele andere Abhängigkeiten gibt auf diesem Board, die so eine Denke gar nicht erst zulassen würden. Aber ich glaube, es gibt irgendwo zwischen der Welt, in der wir heute leben und der Welt, wie sie vielleicht ideal wäre, einen Kompromisszustand, in dem es wenigstens besser wäre. Und was zu verbessern, irgendjemand Schlaues hat das mal hier in diesem Umfeld gesagt, fällt mir gerade gar nicht ein, wer es war, dass man nach dem Unmöglichen streben muss, um wenigstens was Besseres zu erreichen irgendwie. Und das sollte ja schon auch mit unserer Mentalität hier ein bisschen unser Ansatz sein. Und ich glaube, wir brauchen ganz dringend so eine Umdenke, dass es immer nur darum geht, die nächste Generation von irgendetwas zu entwickeln und auf den Markt zu bringen, was nur noch ein bisschen schneller ist und noch ein bisschen besseres Gadget, eine höhere Auflösung, was auch immer, sondern Dinge, die einfach nachhaltiger sind und vielleicht dann mehr Wert darauf legen, dass sie nur das machen, was sie versprechen und dass die Qualität besser ist und dass es eben nicht uns auf die Füße fällt, weil wir Intel sind und Chips gebaut haben, die jetzt irgendwie alle auf einmal angreifbar sind, weil die Ambitionen zu hoch waren. Das fällt uns ja auch auf die Füße. An allen Ecken und Enden ist dieses Rennen, dass wir dem dieses Streben nach immer höher, weiter, schneller, eigentlich was, was vollkommen unlogisch ist und langfristig nicht funktionieren kann.
Und jetzt habt ihr dieses Recycling, wie heißt das eigentlich? Habt ihr einen Namen für das?
Also das ist die Disassembling Station oder so hat das, glaube ich, Dismantling Station, Dismantling Service, genau genommen. Steht da auf so einem LED-Display, was da durchläuft. Ansonsten hat das keinen wirklich großen Namen. Was ich persönlich jetzt so mitnehme, wir wollen ja im Bahnhof auch jetzt ab Herbst startet da ein Repair-Café bei uns. Gehört ja auch so ein bisschen zu der Idee, eines Makerspaces, einer offenen Werkstatt irgendwie dazu. Und ich würde eigentlich sehr gerne die Möglichkeit anbieten, wenn wir was nicht reparieren können, dass wir es dann eben auseinandernehmen und dieses Thema weiter vertiefen, auch gerade mit den Kids. Weil das ist ja auch noch mal ein anderes Problem heute. Der Bezug zu dieser Technologie, also die meisten von uns zumindest können sich vielleicht noch daran erinnern, dass Technologie eigentlich was sehr Wertvolles war, weil wir die Zeiten noch kennen, in denen das alles mal irgendwann richtig teuer war. Und wir halt irgendwie diese, zumindest die Entwicklung mitgemacht haben, dass etwas sehr teuer war und jetzt mittlerweile halt ganz extrem günstig ist. Aber eigentlich wissen wir, dass da wertvolle Dinge drinstecken und das Computer und all das.
Aber es ist schon nicht auch ein Problem, also nicht Problem, aber es ist nicht auch eine Schiene, die man da fahren muss, sondern man sagt, wir slash die alten Menschen, worüber man es sagen will, wissen noch, dass also A, das Software auf Hardware läuft und dass diese Hardware aus verschiedenen einzelnen Bauteilen besteht und nicht sozusagen ein slickes Ding ist, das man in die Hand nimmt, dass man dafür auch ein Bewusstsein schafft, dass die Welt aus Einzelteilen besteht, die man auseinandernehmen kann.
Klar, also das ist ja so ganz klar bei der Arbeit mit jungen Leuten zum Beispiel auch das, was uns ganz wichtig ist. Und ich meine, das ist ein algorithmischer Ansatz, die auch Hardware und die Welt um uns herum und so zu betrachten. Und wenn man dieses Mindset bei jungen Leuten irgendwie etablieren kann, also entweder durch das Lernen vom Programmieren zum Beispiel, funktioniert das ja ganz gut, oder indem man eben auch Dinge auseinanderlötet, oder auch zusammenlötet, wie auch immer, dann versteht man ja, dass das alles irgendwie Bausteine sind. Also Hardware oder Software ist im Endeffekt ja dann auch irgendwie auf der Ebene das Gleiche. Ich bediene mich diverser Bausteine, die ich zusammenfüge, die dann irgendwie funktionieren. Und wenn ein Baustein kaputt ist, dann muss ich den halt irgendwie, muss ich das debuggen und das Problem finden und dann reparieren.
Meinst du, dass die, also was du gerade gesagt hast, irgendwie Dismantling Station mitnehmen in den...
Verstehbaren Hof?
Ich melde das heute noch in den Verstehbaren Hof. Meinst du, man sollte vielleicht, ich mag immer gerne an solchen Stellen dann auch mal irgendwie allgemeine politische Dinge versuchen zu denken, wenigstens, dass man sich als Airfahrer oder Hacker Space oder was auch immer, dass man das sich zum guten Ton in Zukunft angewöhnen, dass wenn ich einen Ort habe, wo ich mit Menschen an Technik arbeite, dass ich dann auch dafür sorge, dass es halt keine Plastiktüten gibt, der Müll getrennt wird und ich eine Dismantling-Station habe.
Also ich glaube, das wäre sicherlich was, was nachhaltig betrachtet das Beste wäre. Ich weiß, auch in Hacker Space ist eine gewisse Challenge, die Ordnungssituation, Mülltrennung zum Beispiel, leidet sehr häufig unter dem, dass die Müllsituation, wer aufräumt, all diese Dinge vielleicht nicht immer optimal geregelt sind. Da gibt es bei ganz einfachen Dingen schon riesiges Potential. Aber trotzdem, selbst wenn man jetzt nur diesen blöden, ist es echt der billigstmögliche Router, den wir da irgendwie haben. Aber auch wenn man den auseinanderbaut, da sind halt auch Schalter drin und Taster. Und das sind im Endeffekt die gleichen Schalter und Taster, wie ich sie irgendwie bei Ebay oder bei Aliexpress oder wo auch immer wir alle so einkaufen, dann bestelle. Und ich habe auf der einen Seite so Geräte, die gucke ich an und denke mir, Scheiße, kann ich nicht mehr wirklich gebrauchen, weg damit. Und auf der anderen Seite bestelle ich halt am gleichen Tag irgendwie ähnliche Bauteile, die ich für irgendwelche Projekte brauche. Und das ist ja auch ein bisschen schizophren. Ich weiß nicht, wie man praktisch bei dem ganzen Elektro-Schrott, der ja um uns herum ständig anfällt, weil er früher oder später ausgetauscht wird oder veraltet ist, wie wir da so skalieren können selber, dass wir wenigstens die Dinge, die da drinstecken, auch rausholen und nicht irgendwie wegfeuern. Aber wir brauchen da, glaube ich, zumindest ein Gespräch drüber und das Bewusstsein, dass das so nicht mehr gut funktioniert.
Wenn ich zufällig jemand vor seinem, ich habe noch zwei praktische Fragen zum Schluss, vor seinem neuartigen Rotfunk-Empfangsgerät sitze und denke, so eine Dismantling-Station, ich bin jetzt kein Hackerspace, aber ich will es mal gerne zu Hause probieren. Zwei Fragen. Die erste, was für Werkzeuge brauche ich, bevor ich den Fall anfange?
Oh, also ein Set Schraubendreher, ein Lötkolben und eine ordentliche Zange, würde ich mal sagen, bringt einen schon relativ weit.
Okay, aber Lötkolben ist schon...
Also je nachdem, wenn ich Sachen von der Platine entfernen möchte, ohne die Zange, dann ist der Lötkolben das nächstgelegene Werkzeug.
Aber das gehört auch dazu.
Oder noch besser, hier waren auch ganz viele Leute mit super großartigen Tipps da die letzten Tage. Das Interessanteste, was ich gehört habe, war eine Pfanne, in die man Lötzinn reingießt, sodass es in Lötzinn Bart gibt. Und dann legt man da die ganze Platine rein und kann dann die einzelnen Bausteine einfach mit der Pinzette runternehmen. Dann nimmt man die Platine wieder raus und dann kommt das nächste so. Wenn ich es so richtig verstanden habe, das würde ich gerne mal testen.
Das geht in exakt die andere Richtung, die ich jetzt gleich tragen wollte, weil ich jetzt eher so dachte, dass man auch, wenn man zu Hause Kids hat, hier Dinge auseinanderbauen, gute Idee, mach mal. Gibt es an Geräten Sachen, die gefährlich werden können, wenn ich die auseinanderbaue?
Ja, also erstmal alles, was so mit Akkus zu tun hat, das würde ich mal lassen.
Also im Sinne von, die nicht anfassen?
Nein, also nicht versuchen Batterien aufzumachen. Gerade so Lithium-Akkus oder sowas. Kann man alles zulassen. Und ansonsten eben überall da, wo stromführende Teile sind, da wäre ich ein bisschen vorsichtig. Ansonsten muss ich ehrlich gesagt passen, jetzt bin ich auch nicht der Spezialist in jedem Bauteil.
Weiß jemand aus dem Publikum, ob man sich am Auseinanderbauen von Leiterplatten wehtun kann oder ob das eigentlich alles ungefähr ist?
Na ja, also du solltest schon gucken, dass du natürlich dich nicht schneidest an der Leiterplatte.
Nein, das klar, dass ich meine, ob da Stoffe drin sind, die, keine Ahnung, niemand weiß.
Also Finger waschen natürlich auch immer. Stromkabel vorher abziehen, nicht hinterher. Ja, okay, gut, dass wir das auch noch mal gesagt haben.
Man weiß ja nie. Bitte was?
Ja, okay, genau, also Bildröhren, alles, ja genau, so was. Fernseher, da kann man schon auch durchaus, fragt mal lieber jemanden, der sowas schon mal gemacht hat.
Zum Beispiel den Verschwörbaren.
Nein?
Das ist kompliziert.
Ich glaube an dieser Stelle beenden wir das Gespräch. Daniel, vielen Dank, dass du da warst, das war sehr schön. So, ich komme aus Berlin, das ist in der Nähe, ich werde demnächst mal vorbeifahren und dann werde ich mir den Namen sicherlich auch merken. Das war es von meiner bzw. unserer Seite, soweit das Chaosradio 254. Wir machen das bald noch voll, also eine Sendung wird es bestimmt noch geben dieses Jahr. Und dann melden wir jetzt noch mal, wie das Format in schön aussehen kann, heute ja ganz ohne Audio, sondern nur das ganz spartanische Wort. Vielen Dank, dass ihr bei wart. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe noch eine letzte Nachricht für euch. Verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups und lasst sie euch nicht überwachen.